- I am so uncomfortable right now.
- Recently we made a video
called "Men get Photoshopped
"Into Ideal Male Body Types."
- It was a look at how
Photoshop affected us as guys.
- What we weren't expecting was this huge
response that women
have to go through this
every single day.
- So, today, we as men are
going to get Photoshopped
to the standards that a
woman would be Photoshopped.
- We have been Photoshopped before,
but never like this.
- [All] Ahh!
(upbeat music)
- So, in all honesty, across media,
how much of beauty is Photoshopped?
- Like all of it.
- All of it?
- Unless an ad specifically says,
"This has not been Photoshopped",
I guarantee it has been Photoshopped.
- It would be really cool
if we lived in a society
where people didn't have
to alter their looks
to be accepted but that's
not the society we live in
and it's been sorta this
way for a long time.
- Sometimes they credit
it back to the pinup era,
like a lot of people
were illustrating women
instead of taking their photos.
And they would exaggerate
the women's bodies
to look like more idealistic
versions of themselves.
- We're constantly looking at
images that have been altered.
We only notice it when it
goes just a step too far.
- So, what we're recreating
today are examples
of disastrous Photoshop.
- Correct.
- Your butt looks so much better already.
- How, what?
So, I'm gonna do the
Victoria Secret underwear ad
where she loses half of her butt.
(laughs)
How does a Photoshop person do that?
- I think that they are
going for a thigh gap.
- Why do people want so much
space between their thighs?
- Like, unfortunately, body
types go in and out of fashion.
Young women, you know, they
want to do what the guy says
is hot.
- You're contouring my eye?
So, I'm doing a Ralph Lauren ad.
What were they thinking?
- The Ralph Lauren in Asia took this ad,
Photoshopped it to what they thought
was the ideal beauty standard.
- Which was smaller.
- Which was very small.
- If I were doing it, I would
probably slim your cheeks
a little bit more and even...
- What's wrong with my cheeks?
And in this context,
being too big is what?
- I think she was like
120 pounds or something.
- You are painting my face like the joker.
I'm recreating a recent
Kim Kardashian photo.
- People are arguing back and forth
whether she did actually
Photoshop the image
regardless, I think the Kardashians
are kind of notorious
for always wanting to use
Photoshop and kind of
look like the best version
of themselves.
- What's going on with the Madonna photo?
- Her before and afters
were incredibly different
and striking.
They took out her wrinkles.
- Airbrushed and just crazy.
- The Madonna photo is your
extreme case of Photoshop.
- Society cuts you off at a certain age
and I think it's so hard for a woman to
age gracefully.
- I mean, I got, a blemish or two.
- You're pretty fucked up, man.
(laughs)
- It really after a while
starts to infiltrate
your own psyche.
The sort of unrealistic
expectation of what
is put out there as a beautiful woman
when really she doesn't
even look like that.
- As a makeup artist, natural means
a lot of makeup to look
like not a lot of makeup.
- People in the fashion industry know
what's going to look good on camera.
- His face is just a little wide.
So, we're trying to bring
it a little bit closer.
- I think that you will learn a lot about
what expectations are put on you.
Even from the moment that
you step into the shoot.
- Normally women do already come prepared
with everything waxed.
- Everything?
- Everything.
- I think a lot of people assume that
a lot of it's done post, but a lot of work
goes into making people
look the way they do
for a cover shoot.
- Oh, there's cream on my thighs.
There's a brush on my butt.
This is a, this is a feeling.
- With celebrities like the
Kardashians are contouring,
and then getting professional
photo shoots done,
and then also Photoshopping,
just seems like a lot of work.
- I would say we're ready for a set.
- How long was that?
- It's like 45 minutes.
- 45 minutes?
- Yeah.
- Ready to paint my naked body?
(upbeat electronic music)
- I thought, "Why are
you touching me up here?
"I thought we already made me beautiful."
- Just a little bit more.
- I'm getting oil rubbed on my body
while another man makes
my butt look better.
- Try so hard to know
that you're beautiful.
And they'll start saying all these things
to you that you're like,
"Woah, I didn't even realize
I had that as a problem."
He's looking a little baggy.
- Baggy?
Are you kidding me?
- This is not untouched.
I've been touched a lot today.
- I've heard celebrities say that's like
an idealized version of me.
And they're like, "I
wish I was like that."
This is the weirdest.
- Try to stick out your
butt as much as possible
and arch your back.
- Move your hips a little back,
but try not to point,
just kinda...
- If you want it long, it has to point.
- Bring that towards us
and push that one back.
- Can you make your butt tighter though?
But not like you're clenching.
- I don't know what you mean.
- Zach?
- Yeah.
- Listen to me.
- No, I'm listening.
- It's hard to arch the
back and get the chin,
'cause I feel like they
must have shopped this.
- Give me a little sultry look,
but less mad.
Less like you're trying.
No, no, no.
Like this, yes.
Like sexy Gollum.
- What has it got in its pockets?
- Can you look a little sexier?
You look very scared right now.
- I mean, in some ways,
I am scared right now.
- I think the most shocking part
might be after you see the
Photoshopped version of yourself,
you basically have seen
what someone wished
that you looked like.
- I'm like, I'm massively contorted here.
- Oh, I'm dying.
How does Kim K. do it?
- It's so hard to not let that affect you.
- [Photographer] Look more seductive.
- Okay.
- [Photographer] And you'll be fine.
- This is a hypersexualized position
and my face is not a part
of who I am at all in this.
- I'm an object.
My face won't even be in the photo.
- Also, think about this.
This is their job.
To look good,
everyday, all day.
- I think we got it.
- Oh ho, ho, ho.
Oh my God.
- I feel terrible.
- I just felt so beaten down
and like there were expectations of me
that I couldn't meet.
- Be angular and hard but
be soft and be seductive
but innocent.
It's like, "What are you?
"I can't be all of these things at once."
- Everything you think
is real is constructed.
Hopefully not in an artful way,
but it's constructed.
- There was nothing human about that.
It's just an object
lit beautifully and now it will be
Photoshopped to look better.
(upbeat music)
- And you don't have her ass.
- No one has her ass.
- I'm both excited and very nervous.
- [All] Woah!
- I think you look beautiful.
- Let's see the photo.
Oh.
- Oh, those arms sure did shrink.
- They look like string beans.
I have bendy straws for arms.
- It's really weird, but
the more I stare at this,
the more normal you look to me.
- I agree.
- Yeah, I'm getting really used to it.
- I know that I'm a very skinny person.
But like, seeing them together, I'm like,
"Oh no, we should take some
of the roundness off that."
Now that I see the one
on the right, I'm like,
"I look chubby as fuck in the left photo."
- Can you imagine being a young girl,
having to look at images like this?
- Since there always will be Photoshop,
stay body positive with the
current body that you have
and to know that where you
are right now, is great.
- So, now we're going
to look at the picture
that I was recreating.
(laughs)
What a nightmare.
Are we ready to see Keith 2 point Oh?
- [All] Oh.
- Gross.
I am a putty man.
I don't like seeing myself like this.
I hate this.
- You don't like being seen as an object.
- No, I don't want to be
seen like a sex object.
I want to be seen as like a fun person.
- But for a woman, this is obviously
not realistic on the right,
but the underwear looks nicer.
- So, they're not only
Photoshopping my body,
they are Photoshopping the product.
So, there's like nothing true, right?
Even when you look at
Golden Grahams on box,
those fucking Golden
Grahams look way better
than the ones in my bowl.
- And if one of these
women were to just release,
you know, a photo of
just what she looked like
when she rolled out of
bed, it would be considered
brave as opposed to just human.
- Madonna.
(laughs)
- Let's see the Photoshopped
version of this.
- Oh, no!
- Holy shit.
- (mumbles incomprehensibly)
- All right, I'm done.
- Why would you do that?
- I'm gone, I'm gone.
- No, that's not me.
Freckles that I have are
what gives me character.
I look like a vampire.
- Also funny is that in
an effort to Photoshop you
to look more like female
Photoshop standards,
your look has gone from "I
will either murder or fuck you"
to "Won't you please come fuck me?"
- Yes, that's true.
- You're right.
- How did they do that?
- And then you come under
fire when a picture of you
comes out that's not Photoshopped.
And they're like, "Why
does she think she needs
"to have so much redone on her?"
And it's like, well
because all you do is tell
her that she doesn't look good enough.
- All right, so, let's see my photo
as Kim Kardashian.
- Are you sitting on your nuts?
- Yeah, I was sitting on my nuts.
- Is like one nut up
your butt hole right now?
- Yeah, we're not gonna talk about it.
- Oh.
- Wow.
- You look like a sexy witch.
- In real life or in the after photo?
- A little of both.
- I feel like I am looking at a painting.
I might have to hang this in my house.
- This should go over your fireplace.
Photoshop is digital painting.
You are so impossibly smooth.
I mean, nobody's back goes so effortlessly
into their butt like that.
'Cause if you stood up,
you would be a nightmare human.
- One good thing though
is people are becoming
more educated about the process
and what it takes to create these images
and how we fit into it as a culture.
- And when you hear
another guy say something
super sexist or body shaming.
- Tell them to shut the fuck up.
- Yeah.
- Go to hell.
- Eat a dick.
You should know that
all of media is altered.
Everyone's trying to be better.
Everyone's putting a better
version of themselves out there,
so you can't judge your raw
self with someone else's
affected self.
- What's going on?
- Um, Kim K is naked in the photo,
so I have to be naked, but,
to honor all the people on
set who should not see my dick
and balls, I'm trying to put
a sock over my dick and balls.
- Not a big enough sock, huh?
- All right.
Try guys.
- I love how you covered
your nipples briefly.
- I feel so exposed.